the Minneapolis Police Chief says the
shooting death of an Australian yoga
teacher by an officer should not have
happened
Justine Damon called 911 to report a
suspected sexual assault on Saturday
state investigators say when police
arrived she was shot and killed by
Officer Mohammad nor people gathered
yesterday to remember Daymond and demand
justice Jamie yuccas is in Minneapolis
Jamie good morning good morning we're at
a memorial that's been erected at the
end of the alley where Justine Damon was
killed speaking publicly for the first
time the Minneapolis Police Chief says
that her death was the act of just one
officer and she's now working to make
changes within the department so people
once again feel safe dialing 911 didn't
have to die Minneapolis police chief
Janee harteau had harsh criticism for
the actions of officer Mohammad nor the
night justine Damon died on her squad
cars you will find the words to protect
with courage and serve with compassion
this did not happen Damon called 911 to
time Saturday after hearing what she
thought was a rape in the alley behind
her home
officers noir and Matthew harity
responded according to state
investigators harity drove down the
alley and said he was startled by a loud
sound
just before Damon appeared at his door
nor fired a single fatal shot from the
passenger seat
killing Damon it is my belief that the
body camera should have been activated
shortly after the press conference
protestors marched through the streets
in south Minneapolis Justine's fiance
Don Damon joined the crowd at a vigil
outside his home by his side the mother
of falando Castile who was shot and
killed by a police officer from a nearby
department last summer we're just here
to support the family officer nor still
has not spoken to authorities his
attorney told me he doesn't intend to
speak until this investigation is
complete as for the police chief she
said she hasn't publicly spoken until
now because she was on a backpacking
trip in a remote area and it was
difficult to get back Norah
all right Jamie thank you so much